Before we dive into more
content let's take a step back.
Here's what you can expect to
learn in the upcoming lessons.
In the first lesson we'll start by
covering how you can generate ideas and
evaluate them against each other.
Then you'll learn techniques for
validating your ideas so
you know you're working on a product
that has a place in the market.
In lesson two, you'll learn about high
level concerns for user experience and
user interaction.
Now you won't be a professional
user experience designer by the end
of the lesson.
Instead, you'll have a strong sense
of the big questions you'd answer
about user experience.
And you also identify common
design elements in products.
With a validated idea from lesson one,
and
the knowledge of user
experience in lesson two,
you'll start to build mock-ups of your
app, or website through a design spread.
You'll learn how start ups get real
feedback from users in just a few days.
This is the same methodology
that Google Venture uses
with startups such as Nest and
Blue Bottle Coffee.
Finally, in lesson four,
you'll learn about metrics, so
you can figure out how to improve
the product and grow the business.
Along the way, you'll be completing
tasks related to the final project.
In the end, you will have gone through
the effort of generating, researching,
validating, and testing a mock
up of your product with users.